I was playing with one of my friends
this one day he had me group up with
three of his friends and as soon as we
lost they were like oh no you know I
don't know why we lost blah blah blah
and so gave this guy criticism and he
just completely flipped out I was
bronzed you know no name random who
cares what you have to think so I got
really pissed and then in that month I
got to rank one and that was when I knew
I was pretty good at legal at it and I
could do it Zachery after mu Black is a
professional league of Legends player
for the team 100 thieves his career has
spanned over seven years in this series
we're telling the stories the people who
continue to make League of Legends the
phenomenon is today from streamer to
star player after uu continues to
captivate fans with his skilled play
outgoing personality and determination
to drive his team to victory today we're
looking back at his career defining
moments which shaped him into one of the
most recognizable faces in his works
very good understanding of
that's the kill picked up absolutely
beautiful to push himself that way
x-rays after the cleanse from afro move
and a lot of hitches down here towards
the bottom at the infertility
he is feeling it a bull's-eye for him
with that hook yeah my parents weren't
really supportive when I was balancing
college and League of Legends so well
hop playing they would cut off the
internet for like a month
took away my PC for at least two months
but after a little while Wednesday
realized you can make money doing this I
enjoy it and you know I'm giving a
hundred cent of my effort towards what I
want to do today finally you know caved
in and started supporting me a lot and
now my dad is insane because he always
tells me you should try this new pic you
know the passion nose hit and he's like
Oh Zach did you try this new build on
borrowed I'm like dad you know I think
it's cool and I like talking to him with
it about the game early days of pro play
was when like the amateur scene I guess
was around before LCS so we would play
like Team solomid invitationals IPL's
who got MLG's and it would just be a
random ragtag team that wasn't any
guarantee that you know this could keep
going as a livelihood until right
introduced LCS and I really wanted to
play video games professionally CLG was
holding tryouts for support and I was a
80k I mean at the time for like three
years and I was like okay I can probably
do support and that was when doublelift
had hit me up in soloqueue
to come try out for seal G so I tried
out they really like me I'm not drinking
my first impressions of aphromoo as a
player when I saw him was a leader
someone who wasn't afraid to speak out
and be vocal he was this super vocal
player that really rallied the team but
around like a team play around a
five-man thing and I was someone who was
extremely selfish and only wanted the
team to play around me
we were totally opposites but I think
the funny thing is like we got along
super well we became friends like
instantly and we we've been friends ever
since you brought two of the biggest
personalities together for the first
time and what was rush hour and double F
and Afra Muin it was on one of the
biggest teams I mean TSM and CLG were up
there like the pinstripes the Yankees
the matter
they're always fighting for the pennant
and now you have two of them on the same
team it just ignited this sort of fandom
and and I don't know what started it all
like I'm not sure exactly but you had
some those popular players were very
very good who you know put together a
duo and CLG was pretty good freak came
by and said something about rush hour
and then you know what sort of spammy
rush hour after that and then once we
got to LCS and since we were performing
so well you know best bottom lane that
name just stuck
we were rush hour and every ball II knew
that they were playing it's rush hour it
was gonna be impossible the way shall we
shout Goes Down that was beautiful
they're not even done yet kid - Adrian
they're gonna get this done with one
more head they get them way too close
now for CLG triple kill for turtle
looking for the Quadra
at that time it's a triple for
doublelift he's like a
[Applause]
the troubles that doublelift an afro Moo
I guess we only knew they face towards
the end we're all apparently because
these are the two best guys in the
league
there's the Nexus c9 get to buy in the
playoffs the bottom Lane was a huge
issue for CLG when you get to that level
of play it's understandable these guys
are going to be butting heads a little
more intense when somebody makes a
mistake because you're held to such a
high regard you know definitely didn't
feel it was good to keep the same roster
you know something had to change and I
didn't really at the time didn't really
want to play with double F anymore since
we played for about four years and I
feel like you know need to change I
think when you know I gotta use it after
like issued the ultimatum that he wanted
me off the team or like he was gonna
leave then I was definitely really salty
but after a while after my initial kind
of like bitterness towards the situation
I realized that that's fine like I wish
that he had told me just more bluntly
that he had a problem with my attitude
or he had a problem with like the things
I did in the past but it also like take
some ignorance on my parts and I
realized it so after a while like I
think it was fine in late 2015
doublelift left the team a firm you
would continue to play on CLG for two
years going to Worlds and MSI after a
long career with CLG aphromoo moved on
and hunt for a new team out of the ten
LCS teams starting in season eight seven
approached him with competitive offers
he would enter a new age for League of
Legends under 100 thieves coming from
CLG 200 thieves I've learned a lot about
you know who I am as a person how I want
to be towards my teammates since moving
different team dynamics and stuff like
that working with him to try to like
solve any problems always really easy
because I think he's just a really good
listener
and make sure that you're not too mad or
about anything and you know we can just
talk to Manta men I think afros now a
household name in his own right and that
is awesome that he has gotten so much
better that he's built his own brand in
all of his fans and and he is a player
you go out and grab just by himself
because of what he can do and what he
can bring to a team right very first
split makes the final hundred thieves
right that's no accident he is a truly
incredible player and that growth has
been awesome aphromoo has been able to
help build the scene but also show other
players that building a brand is
something that also is very accessible
in that position and it helps you grow
and I think we've seen now for MU the
year-over-year become exceedingly bigger
because of that approach to loving the
fans loving the game and wanting to help
other people understand that more afros
biggest strength is definitely as I've
heard plays so he can visualize a play
and he can then after visualizing and
get a CMAs execute on it really well I
think right now I think it's fair to
consider afternoo the best support in
North America potentially of all time
what I want to accomplish is definitely
win a title under hundred themes I got
to unseal G as well as make it to Worlds
400 days think that's one of the big
things especially in the new franchise
league after the legends
I really enjoyed variety shaming in
terms of just playing other games for
fun and I would most likely just be a
content creator streaming variety games
after this yeah I'll be playing games
for the rest of my life until I back
a console in my grave like um I guess
[Music]
in the next episode of this series we're
going to be breaking down the science of
play with pros and analysts to figure
out what's going on in our brains we're
playing an intense game like League of
Legends and what separates everyday
players from truly great competitors
[Music]
you